these rocks are much more valuable than
diamonds for eons they lay on the
surface of a tiny ancient asteroid half
a kilometer wide called bennu until they
were mined with a puff of air by a robot
billions of kilometers from Earth bennu
was just a shadow on a telescope survey
when it was discovered in 1999 but it's
rich in carbon and it's older than the
earth so in 2016 NASA sent osiris-rex to
collect and return a sample asteroids
are among our most primitive bodies in
the solar system so being able to return
samples from them is like taking a time
machine back four and a half billion
years ago to be able to see what the
building blocks were for our Earth and
all the planetary bodies in our solar
system sealed in a capsule the precious
cargo will land on a patch of Utah on
Sunday morning
this is just the latest attempt in a
long history of sending robots to
collect rocks from space in 1972 the
Soviet Lander Luna dug into the moon's
surface collected about a hundred grams
of material put it in a capsule and shot
it back to Earth
in 2006 NASA collected dust from a
comet's tail in an operation called
Mission Stardust now Japan was the first
country to grab a piece of an asteroid
their first attempt the Hayabusa probe
landed twice on one and nearly failed
Upon returning to Earth but managed to
deliver Trace Amounts of dust they tried
again and in 2020 they returned five
grams of pristine material from the
surface of an asteroid and China's lunar
lander Chung E5 in 2020 managed to send
back two whole kilograms of lunar
material
each of these grams and kilograms of
space rock is still yielding clues about
the formation of our solar system from
the composition of the lunar soil to the
complex organic molecules necessary for
life that are locked away deep in space
and new discoveries are expected to be
found in tiny grains like these some as
small as a virus
in the case of Stardust which were Comet
samples just from a single tiny grain
smaller than a human hair we were able
to
set bounds on when Jupiter formed and to
know about how much oxygen was present
in the early solar system
there's utility in this as well because
there's a very small chance that bennu
could crash into Earth in a century and
a half so learning about it now could
help prepare the Next Generation for
another possible Celestial meeting Colin
Baker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera